I was interviewing an Argentinian film
director yesterday and he said you're
all becoming Latin America because
that's what happens in Latin America is
presidents are arrested the law is used
as a political process it happened in
Italy with Berlusconi who's just died
it's happening in Scotland with Nicholas
sturgeon it's happened to a certain
extent with Boris Johnson it's a sort of
lower key less legal thing than Donald
Trump yeah because initially police say
initially police there's a legal element
and it is it's lawfare it is the use of
the law or official privilege
parliamentary procedures
to remove someone from power or to make
it impossible for someone to win back
power I don't think that's very
Democratic I think with Boris Johnson I
think a lot of people would have been
quite happy to vote him out that should
be how it was it shouldn't be he's you
know put away by a court